well good evening everybody good
afternoon today ladies and gentlemen
it's fantastic to to to see you all here
and i know that you'll have been paying
attention
scrupulously to everything i've been
saying throughout this
extraordinary summit but i want to
remind you of some key figures that you
you are worth remembering and
i just want to remind you that when i
was a kid in this country we got 80
of our power from coal
when i was mayor of london and i first
met some of my fellow uh world leaders
and we got 40
of our power from coal today that figure
is down to one percent and it's going to
zero by 2024. we're going to get into
zero emissions for our vehicles for our
new cars by 2030 and we're going to net
zero for our whole power generation
sector by 2035 not even making use of of
gas how is it possible
to do this
how it's it's through technology through
the promethean power of human invention
that is what is enabling us to make uh
the progress that we are and i want to
see here from uh the glasgow
breakthroughs a new surge of initiatives
to deal with some of the outstanding
problems let me give you one in
particular
and
that is aviation and it's a tough nut to
crap and uh we're spending i think i can
see bill gates dimly over there i got
bill i can see bill gates now bill and i
thank you bill and i just agreed uh
jointly to spend i think 400 million
pounds trying to solve the problems of
of low carbon aviation zero uh
guilt-free uh aviation and we've gotta
fix it i'm gonna be flying in a a plane
quite soon uh that has i think 35
percent sustainable aviation fuel uh i
mean and the top the target at the
moment is to get to to 10 sustainable
aviation fuel for the whole world by
2030. how pathetic is that we can do
better than that folks it was a hundred
years ago that uh that uh all [ __ ] and
brown i think it was all [ __ ] and brown
uh flew the atlantic for the first time
didn't they with about 865 imperial
gallons of of petrol we've made
virtually no progress technologically
since then uh in our approach to sending
a plane up over the uh up over the
atlantic i want to see alok
i want to see never mind all [ __ ] i want
to see alok as the as the skipper of the
next jet zero uh plane that will
will not rely on fossil fuels at all i
think that we should we should be far
far more ambitious and i just want to
say thank you to his his royal highness
uh the duke of cambridge because i think
the earth shot prize is a terrific
initiative and i've just met
some young people who've got
plans for getting rid of uh for a
there's a machine over there about the
size of a microwave
looks suspiciously like a microwave
actually
that apparently can make very cheap
hydrogen isn't that fantastic i i
believe it i'm a taker she she gave me
her card
this could be the this could be the
future i think that we can crack these
problems and there are basically uh five
key areas where we want to see the
breakthroughs take place they're in
they're in transport they're in steel
they're in hydrogen they're in
agriculture and above all they're in
power generation and we can fix it go
back to that initial statistic that i
began with we can do extraordinary
things you may not think that the
weather is particularly beautiful here
in the uk actually it's wonderful isn't
it the weather's not too bad today it's
been fantastic it hasn't been quite up
to kenyan standards uru but it's been
pretty pretty sunny today and there are
many days in which thanks to our
combination of solar and wind we produce
more than 50 percent of our energy from
renewables what we want the whole
objective of this summit now is to take
these inventions take these
breakthroughs and get the finance get
the support to make sure that they are
disseminated they are spread around the
whole world so that the whole world
shares in the glasgow breakthroughs and
shares in our agenda and that we unite
across the whole planet to tackle to
tackle with uh to tackle climate change
and there's one guy who particularly
understands how to do that and who
shares that agenda and who understands
that a single hour
a single hour of sunshine
provides enough energy to power the
whole earth
for a year you know that the power all
human activity on earth i should say
for a year